I think that's it's fair to say that
Harrison Ford to the pioneer in his own
work on conservation international in
spite of extraordinary career also well
known that nothing more need be said
about it here he is found time a lot of
time going back for years to engage in
the planning and the and the carrying
out of important conservation projects
around the world particularly in
tropical areas where most of the species
of organisms live and whether the most
are threatened with extinction as a
board member of Conservation
International for example where I served
for a period of time while he was one of
the most effective members so I'm not
sure that I've really had an influence
on the Harrison Ford I've just been very
proud to be working with him